acabaram de presenciar foram dois
trunfos usados pelos políticos
aparecerem liners o primeiro entrar pelo
lado esquerdo
nós moramos quatro segundos de criar a
primeira opção porque é importante
entrar do lado esquerdo porque forma
como nós lemos é mais fácil
somos melhor é fazer com que o público
conhecia ninguém ou quase ninguém porque
amigável e estes truques usados pelos
políticos
vou partilhar hoje é quem é que tem
postura ousada juntas ensinar truques
melhorar a memória ea obtenção de
informação como é que podem ter uma
melhor memória cruzem os braços abertas
tão simples quanto isto e aquilo que eu
vou partilhar hoje é muito importante e
vou lançar uma pergunta o que é um líder
um líder mas sim que eu encontrei um
lida é que o corinthians
o teste era cliente e flexível tem a ver
com as palavras transmitem e idéias o
jest às pressões do movimento
transmitindo se não houver congruência
entre as palavras e os gestos não vai
haver congruência entre as idéias e as
emoções ea equipe muitos líderes
falharam na comunicação
e agora pergunto mais uma coisa o que
comunicar
será que é
são as palavras que o júri será que o
jest que o faço no twitter dizem que o
olhar o mundo já teresa caeiro patia
agora para mim comunicar no eu que o
digo um mês cinco vocês percebem do que
o digo
imagine a primeira não há muitas pessoas
dizem que sou universo e entrou nos
locais
assim o flu lidera
confiei em mim vocês confiavam
eu disse que era ler
daí a importância da linguagem corporal
se não for congruente com as palavras da
comunicação falha e também com uma
equipe nós comunicamos palavras o tom de
voz ea linguagem corporal uma interação
frente a frente
quanto é que acham que valem as palavras
dizer 100% 40%
podemos falar que acha que é mais 50%
quem acha que é mais 30% quem acha que
20 que acha que ele é quem acha que é
certo a importância das palavras uma
interação frente a frente quando eu
interajo com alguém aí as pessoas não se
vão lembrar do que hoje diz vou lembrar
e como é que os fez sentir que há muita
gente se prepara mais responder às
palavras que diz do que treinando a
linguagem corporal e e kico
agora pergunto eu será e suturas
linguagem corporal
sabe esse truque todos e é fácil
qualquer um de vocês pode usar a
linguagem cultural para otimizar a
liderança ou seja aquilo foi o que vocês
quiserem vir a criar credibilidade e
confiança
mostrar a autoestima tudo isto vem
fazendo através do leite preto
vim por sendo as nossas ações geram 80%
de nossos resultados
isto é se otimizar em 2060 minha imagem
do river ou seja do fórum aplicar 25 dos
truques e de dizer vamos otimizar a
vossa imagem e 80% e outro e alguma a
gente senta e euller o outro
basta receber 20 do jet mais importante
tenho conseguido fazer é de intenções de
toda a gente com quem o livro é tão
simples conquista não precisam de saber
tudo pra ler ea pessoa otimizarem nossa
linguagem
basta 20% desta linguagem e hoje quero
dar também o superpoder não gostava de
ficar atrás também quero dar um
superpoder e chama super poder de
antecipação
isto é quando nos cruzamos resposta
já temos que reagir à pessoa com
linguagem corporal você agora podem se
para se perceber se a pessoa está
confortável topo estão a dizer ou não se
ela está de acordo com você joão ou
então se está a contento ou não os então
vai questionar ou desafiar a vossa
liderança e hoje manter e se perder
vamos falar sobre os 20 por cento mais
importante
o primeiro contato ocular o contacto
ocular de um líder começar a ser a que o
contato ocular intenso
será que salta contato contato ocular de
um líder tem que ser simpática empate
que confiante
muitas vezes dizem que falta vontade
popular tassia da mentira o que é
mentira porque a falta de contato ocular
o que demonstra falta de autoestima ou
confiança
o contato popular do líder deve ser
negra 7 para 1
olha certo tive um pode ser o segundo
time 1
tão simples quanto isto tem que
experimentar porque jesus é mesmo a
segunda é como é que o encontro no cairo
como é que eu tenho lucas vocês sabem
como é que como é que entraram nesta
sala o que chama da paixão por um tempo
você me frente viram a forma como
costumam andar no dia a dia é forma como
são percebidos no dia a dia pelas outras
pessoas
o evento está a andar com o queijo na
horizontal tronco
toda a gente sabe que os níveis das
pessoas que querem demonstrar liderança
como é que o sexto andar com posturas
abertas
ambos para trás tão simples quanto isto
não façam isto a não ser que seja
estritamente necessário porque tem uma
postura fechada e de submissão unidas
tem que ter posturas abertas e agora vou
partilhar um segredo
se quiserem saber quem está interessado
em falar com vocês
a gente sabe de verdade vejo para onde é
que ponto o umbigo deu por ela neste
momento em que estou interessado em ver
a partir de hoje vão saber quando
estiverem interage gol e aí amigos
também poderemos apontar umbigo é onde
está o meu interesse é tão simples
quanto isto não as mãos são os melhores
formas de isolar a liga falhou na
comunicação porque querem transmitir
diretivas como eu tenho a minha mão eu
quando tem as palmas das mãos viradas
para cima eu não estou exercer a
autoridade o que estou a fazer é pedir
colaboração e pedir ajuda
é pedir a compreensão de todos
agora se eu quiser dar uma ordem uma
diretiva
como é que eu devo fazer viro as palmas
das mãos para baixo e sim que nós
devemos transmitir uma ordem uma
diretiva
não a mensagem vai perder imagineering
hoje vamos todos pagar
não faz muito sentido atenção até o
píton muda conforme o vírus mãos tão
simples quanto isto
usei as mãos para amplificar as vossas
palavras e agora nos pés o que é que os
mesmos dizem domínio se eu sou dominante
ou não ou para onde é que eu quero ir
líder raramente fala com os pés juntos
que os níveis das pessoas mais
dominantes querem exercer a autoridade
tem tendência a ocupar mais espaço e tem
maior escritores meus carros é por causa
disso e nós que fazemos como líder de
quando conhecemos essa lembrança é essa
estamos com os pés aos que afastam
enviado mas também não é por aí que
vocês vão ganhar também o ideal é que os
pés estejam ao nível dos ombros para ser
reconhecidos como confiante e com uma
melhora a autoestima e agora espero que
indicam mais eu quero ir com quem eu
quero estar lá eu sou um amigo problema
aponta os pés fazem a mesma coisa se eu
tiver um pé apontar preço ladrão eu
tenho 13 deste lado mas sempre tentei sp
está virado para a porta quer dizer que
eu quero é ir embora
por isso agora já se encontrou com deus
quiser embora a jogar com os pés
vejo o interesse das pessoas pela
direção que os pais tomam isto é
demasiado importante para ficar
esquecido
e por fim o aperto não 90% das nossas
interações começam com um aperto de mão
o efeito mal um caso ainda não saibam
vai influenciar toda a interação daí pra
frente
conseguem receber pessoas conquistam
interagir vai interagir em salvar
superioridade ou inferioridade
simplesmente pelo aperto mau exercício
cumprimento ao lado
não vamos lá toda essa força força força
foi o primeiro a completar não pode
apagar a tatuagem comprimento rock fest
estofar largas mãos
estou no paraná estou agora
lembra se cometem as mãos a posição de
não ter a ajuda do paulo premê ajudar a
explicar esses podem chegar às mãos
imaginem que o tom vai cumprimentar com
apertos de mão
o que eu posso descobrir o paulo tem
bumbum bonito é mais difícil o dobro de
down é uma coisa que não olha pra mim é
80 o que aconteceu
o paulo neste momento ricky seo que eu
vou dominar toda a interação daqui pra
frente
simplesmente o que é porque eu
cumprimentei o com a palma da mão para
baixo lembra os braços eram antigamente
cumprimentá los assim que elas faziam
armados em forte acontece a mesma coisa
com o irmão eu modificou-se assim e por
já pessoas antes de cumprimentar o que
eles fazem
assim começa a olhar para isso
durante o vôo dominar o tema e ração de
agora também posso fazê lo de outra
forma que é com palma da mão pra cima o
que estou a fazer é reconhecer que sou
inferior e e quem frio não quer dizer
como pessoas tutu atendimento seja o que
for
por reconhecer esse domínio da parte do
paulo como é que um conto um aperto não
deve ser na vertical e firme e firme
agora pergunto a vocês perguntam de que
o artista está armada e superior e e
agora como é que eu vou fazer
imagine como tal vai complementar
coppola não virada para cima para baixo
cumprimento o palma da mão é o e agora
como é que eu vou fazer
será que vou brigar nas mãos do usuário
não faz sentido
vou partilhar um pequeno grande truque
o paulo é dominante o que aconteceu eo
que eu faça
para ela tal êxito
basta dar um pequeno passo à frente com
a perna esquerda e automaticamente como
eu não quero tocar no meu umbigo é não
vira é automático
agora outro tipo bastante simples e
palma da mão em cima mas que pode
acontecer
o paulo é mais porque hoje em dia você
quer que eu tenho que fazer é vasco
esquerda e volta 35 saída de emergência
sempre com esta situação agora
por fim por fim e muito obrigado por uma
salva de palmas ao projeto
por fim quero lembrar que a linguagem
cultural é baseado importante para não
levar em conta há muitas pessoas que são
lidas dentro delas próprias
mas não consegue trazer essa liderança
para fora e muita culpa é da linguagem
corporal não é o mais importante na
liderança mas é uma das coisas mais
importantes
eu acredito que tenha o carisma será o
mais importante na liderança mas que a
linguagem corporal ajuda é transmitir em
essa liderança
acredito quero agradecer a vossa atenção